まずは正思惟ということを学んでみましょう
八正道の正 正八正道の2番目
サンマサンカッパというんですね
これは正思惟というんです
正しい思考 思考妄想は制御不可能で
勝手に暴走しているんですね
我々の頭は 我々に思考の自由はないんです
よく平気で嘘言ってるでしょ
思考の自由とか言論の自由とか
どこにあるんですかね
あるわけないんです 言論の自由どころか
思考の自由はあるんですかね
我々にできますかね 思考を変えることは
ワンパターンでぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる同じ思考をしているでしょうに
変えられないでしょう
常に悪思考が流れているので
それが善思考になるように管理するんです
我々の思考が悪思考ですよ
もう決まってるんです
悪思考に 誰も良い思考はしません
たまに間違って良い思考をしても
すぐ分解していきます
はい ですから思考を整理するんです
で マッジムニカへの 141番目の経典でサッチャイバンガスッタンというんですね
その経典からたった一行だけです
取っているのは 正しい思惟と言われたら
具体性はない 実行もできない
お釈迦様も正思惟と言ったっても
あれって何？どんな何が正しいんですかね？思考の場合は全くもう
漠然として実行できないでしょうに
そんなのは科学的じゃないんです
はい 我は正しい思考をするそうと言って何する？我は正しい言葉を語るそうと言って何語る？どうやって判断する？不可能ですよ
しかし お釈迦様は八正道
8つの正しい道であると
ブッダ 仏教はと教えています
お釈迦様は大雑把でも漠然と喋れません
精密に語るんです お釈迦様
1gと言ったらもう 1.000000なんです
1gぐらいじゃないんです
仏教では まあそれ例え話で
もしお釈迦様がもう何とか何とか 1g使ってくださいと言ったら
化学秤に入れて 0.000000
になるように測らなくちゃいけないんです 1
と言ったら1です 99
なんとか 0.9999999も1ではありません
どこまで9が進んでも
この精密なんですよ 仏教は
ですから難しいの この心理の世界
心理学の心の世界でしょ
そこを語れるのかと そこほど精密的に語れますよ
ブッダだけは それで悪思惟は三つで
正思惟は三つです 三つにしているんです
これ六つでしょ でも本当は三つで理解できるようにしているんです
悪思考というのは三つにしているんです
良い思考は三つにしているんです
それで順番で まず悪思考を止める
悪思考を止めなくちゃいけないんです
悪思考さえ止めてくれれば
まず OK です 思考の管理はしません
思考の自由は置いておくんです
ただ これだけやめてくださいと
他どうそうと考えてくださいと
それから善思惟を 善思惟を実践するんです
悪思考をやめて落ち着いたところで
まあポジティブに善思考にも挑戦すればいいんです
はい 思考の整理  1 1 はカーマサンカッパ
五欲に関わる思考 楽しみたい
儲けたい 贅沢をしたい
旅行したい 成功したいなどなど
思考でしょ  1 日中やってますからね
1 日中欲のことばっかり考えているんですね
これは悪思考です 考えるたびに心は汚れる
不幸になる 病気になる
罪を犯すことになります
軽々とやっても罪を犯してますよ
儲かりたい 儲かりたい
儲かりたいと思うたびに罪を犯っているんです
だからでしょう このそういう人々は儲からないのは
何も思わず気楽に行動すればうまくいくのに
だからまずそれをやめるんですね
欲に関する妄想をやめるんです
頭に中に何か妄想がよぎり始めたら
あ これは欲やと あ 欲はやめますと
欲の思考はやめると それだけやめる
他は考える で ネッカマサンカップ
五欲から離れた欲を乗り越えて脱出する方向へ思考する
はい まず時間かかりますよ
悪思考で出ればやめる
出たらやめる 出たらやめる
出たらやめる 悪思考ではなくて
欲の思考 電車でなんか変なものを見てね
欲が出てきたら さっさとその場でその思考をカットして
別なもの じゃあ広告でも読もうかとかね
電車の あるいはじゃあもう本でも読みましょうとかね
何か別なことをして まあその思考だけやめてみる
それでどんどん慣れていくんですよ
それから悪思考はないようになります
心はすごい綺麗な人間ですよ
怪しげな人間でなくなっちゃうんです
万引きする人間でなくなっちゃうんです
物を盗む不正を働く人間でなくなっちゃうんです
自分のものでない金の束があったってもね
全然もう気持ち悪くなるだけ
これを取って届けなくちゃいけない
それでも気持ち悪いと
届けるつもりで取っただけでも泥棒扱いされるかもしれませんよとかね
それぐらいものすごい心はきれいになりますよ
もう時間かけて日にちかけて欲思考を抑える
それからその代わりにネッカンマサンカッパ始めるんです
ネッカンマサンカッパっていうのは特定の思考なんですね
欲から離れる思考 いきなりできません
これは優れた善なる思考で
たとえ妄想であっても優れた思考です
あ 全部はもう仕事も金も全部家ももうからも離れたいとかね
もう体にやる執着もやめたいとかね
お規制するのをやめたいとかね
で 何にも依存しないでいたいなとか
妄想であってもね 綺麗な思考なんです
五感に束縛されて奴隷として働く心の自由解放を考えるんです
この 2番目は難しいんですよ
我々は奴隷なんです 五感の奴隷なんです
五感の奴隷はダメやと
自由になりたいとと思う思考なんですね
何でも獲得することではなく
捨てることについて考える
もう獲得することはよくわかるでしょう
あれ欲しい これ欲しいという生き方だからね
いえ 自分持っているものはもうまあ面倒くさいな
こんなものあってとかね
自由がなくなっているんだと
部屋にいろんな品物が増えると
生きている人の自由がなくなるんでしょうね
便利になるんじゃないんですよ
あれはもう俗世間はそう思ってるんですね
電子レンジを買ってきて
便利になったとか 自由がなくなるんです
じゃあパソコンも買いましょうと
ああ 便利 便利になってないんです
それでも自由がなくなってるんです
大変ですからね ちょっとしたたらぶったら
あっちこち電話して いろんな苦労をしなくちゃいけないんですね
2番目に入ります ヴィーパッサナーサンカッパ
瞋恚 激しい怒り 憎しみに属する思考
妄想 欲をやめたところで
すぐ怒りの妄想をやめるんです
気持ち悪いとかね なんであいつは？とかね
そういう思考はもうやめる
エゴ 傲慢と卑下慢は自我の錯覚の表と裏です
瞋恚の源です このなんで怒るんですか？というエゴなんですね
傲慢なんですね 世の中自分で管理できないでしょうに
自分がものすごい小さな存在でしょうに
なんで世間に向かって怒るんですかね
態度でかすぎなんですね
もう恐ろしいね 頭の悪さは
もうちょっと理性があったら怒れないはずなんでしょうに
誰が声が高いとか 誰の言葉の使い方が悪いとか
あなたに管理できるんですかね
そんなのはと 麻生さんの政権もよくないとか
じゃあやってみたんでできるんですかね
仕えることもできんだからね
放っておきましょう あれにこれに怒るは怒るは怒るは
電車が満員で乗りにくい
だから何するの？と あなたのために特別な天皇家じゃないんだからね
特別に電車が走ってくれるとか
天皇陛下なら新幹線でも旅はしますけど
特別な新幹線で一般人が乗れない
そんな調子でいるんだからね
みんな ですから本当はちょっと理性があったら微塵も怒りません
そういうことで このエゴ
傲慢がありますね 時々人々はすごい卑下慢で
私は何者でもないと思っている場合もありますよ
あれも傲慢の裏なんですね
結局エゴなんです 卑下慢も傲慢もエゴなんです
それがあると怒るんですよ
もう神様の気分になるんですね
悪思考で思考するたびに罪を犯すことになります
だから簡単にやりますけど
我々は多大な罪を犯しているんです
瞋恚の妄想 思考が現れると
ですから そういう怒りが来たらすぐそこでストップするんですね
それで反対 アッビヤパサンカッパというんですね
慈しみにですね 瞋恚が消えるような思考です
だから慈しみでなくてもいいんです
怒りが消えるような思考で十分です
今 私はその例を出しましたからね
この巨大な世界の中で
自分が何者でもないんだから
もう落ち着いていればいいんです
この神様の気分になるんじゃないんです
あまりにもひどいんです
そんなことは そう思っちゃうと怒りが出てこない
あるいは慈しみを育てる
みんな同じやと みんな苦しんでいるんだと
卑しい思考を真偽が消える慈しみの思考で置き換える
だから怒りというこの卑しい思考をね
慈しみで全ての生命が幸福でありますようにという行動の思考で置き換えればいいんです
そこで怒りというのは 1
自分 2他人 3物事について怒るんですね
自分に怒る 他人に怒る
物事に怒る 自分と他人に対して慈しみを育てる
生き物だから 物事に対して冷静を求めるんです
それは慈悲喜捨の捨なんですね
世の中の出来事については冷静でいる
生命に対しては慈しみでいるということで
思考のコントロールできます
はい 思考の整理 悪い方はヴィヒンサーサンカッパというんですね
他人に害を与える思考
妄想 加害者思考 暴力思考
いじめる気持ち もありますね
結構ありますよ 臆病であっても
私にこの妄想はありませんとは言えません
時々何かみんな調子に乗って
私はそんな加害者的な思考ないんだとかね
偉そうにカッコつけようと思っちゃいますけどね
なおさら悪いんです あるあるんですよ
人に害を与えたいと貶したい
怒鳴りたい やっつけたいという気持ちはみんなにあるんです
生きることは結局弱者いじめ
殺し 弱者殺しですよ 私は本当にもう臆病者で
こんな人いじめなんかもう毛頭もないとかね
控えめていたって生きてるでしょうね
生きてるということは
弱者いじめなんです 他人殺すことなんです
では 世の中の生命を見てください
堂々と生きる生命は必ず大量に殺生していますよ
誰でも生きるということは
やっぱり弱者いじめなんです
そんなに褒めるものじゃないんです
生きることは これも悪思考で
妄想するたびに罪を犯すんです
はい 次に行きます その反対はアヴィヒンサーサンカッパというんですね
だいたい 1番目以外はあつけるだけ
わかりやすく ヴィヒンサーサンカッパにa入れてアヴィヒンサーサンカッパというんです
あのaっていうのはパーリ語では否定形なんですね a
というのはアなんですね
アヴィヒンサーサンカッパ
非暴力思考 あまりに言われる慈しみですね
の思考なんですね 他人の苦しみを感じて幸福を願う思考
慈悲念 どうすれば助けることができるのかと考えることですね
いじめたいではなくて
ああ かわいそうですねとかね
なんとか助けてあげればいいなとかね
生命の苦しみを発見して
なんとかした方がいいんじゃないかなと
世界は幸福になった方がいいんじゃないかなと
戦争がなくなって平和になった方がいいんじゃないかなとか
貧困がなくなった方がいいんじゃないかなとかね
そういうふうな思考を育てていくんです
あの人は敵だから あの国は敵国だからね
潰したいっていうのは
それはもうとんでもない罪なんです
なんとか助ける方法はないのかとかね
考えなくちゃいけないんです
自分と他人に対してカルナーとカルナーというんですね
仏教では それには物事に対して自然を守ることです
で 怒りも三種類ですね
自分に怒る 他人に怒る
物事に怒る この場合の暴力も三種類です
自分に対する暴力 他人に対する暴力思考
それから自然破壊する
自然の資源を取りたい放題
取って取って取って取って
他人に立ち入り禁止にして
このやっている世界はね
釈尊そのものだからね
そういうのはもうこの思考に入りますね
暴力主義に入ります ですから
良い方向では自分に対して
他人に対して哀れみを持つんです
ああ 苦しませてはあかんと
自分も苦しませてはあかんです
いけないんですね 他人も苦しませては悩ませてはいけないと思うこと
自然の場合は自然を守りましょうと
その三つでできちゃうんです
それで完了です 思考の改革は
はい それで私は今日時間ないんだから説明できませんだけど
お釈迦様は完璧に喋ってます
これで世界のあるすべての宗教家が言っている道徳よりもはるかに完全に語っています
仏教で自然を守ることを何も言ってないんではないか
そんなことは何も文句言えません
仏教に対しては 社会福祉活動をやってないんですか？とか
それは悪人やるんだからね
いじめたんだから 弁償しなくちゃ
損害賠償しなくちゃあかんだからね
で 完了の問題 思考妄想の整理改良は以上の 3つで完了です
複雑にややこしく語ると
さらに思考が混乱するのです
実践できないのです だから
このあんまり複雑にして語ると
頭がぐちゃぐちゃになって実践できないんです
例えば キリスト教では愛という言葉があるんだけど
説明するはするはするはもうわけもわからないんですね
結局は どうやって実行すればいいかわからなくなっちゃうんです
だってあの異性の欲も愛ですね
人を助けるのは愛なんですね
何やこれと まるっきり心理学的に違うでしょうに
異性のことを自分のわがままでしょうに
自分のために欲しいと思う
これは愛でも何でもないんですね
エゴそのものなんです
心汚れるんです 困ってる人はもういいえ
助けてあげますよということは我儘じゃないんだから
それは良いことでしょうに
その区別さえもないんです
だからそういう話を聞くと
もう頭が混乱しちゃって実践できない
だからブッダは3つに分けてるだけ
それにすべて入るようになっているんです
釈尊はあの完成者ですね
何を語っても完全に語る
これ以上も以下もありません
仏典を読んでみたら まあこれで終わり
これ以上もないし以下もないんです
はい これ面白いことはなんで無知がないんですかね
あの思考の整理に だって貪瞋痴で無知で感情で
で 妄想してるでしょ 妄想すると当然バカでしょ
で 無知はないんですね
なんかお釈迦様忘れたんですかね
これちょっと怪しいんですよ
無知がないんです あったのは欲と2種類の怒りなんですね
瞋恚と暴力 なんでまた欠けてる
無知だから思考妄想のボリュームが起こるが
無知そのものの管理はできませんよ
だからできないことを言ってもね
意味がないでしょうに
手を叩いて空飛んでくださいと言うのはできますけど
実行できませんでしょうに
だって鳥たちの翼も手ですよと
鳥たちは手を叩いて空を飛べるんだからね
じゃあ私たちもと こんな
それ自体がアホなことなんです
だから無知の管理できないんです
無知の無知の妄想をすると
妄想していることにも気づきません
怒りが出てくると 怒っているんだと気づきますけど
欲が出てくると 今私は欲で恋で今恋真っ最中やとわかるんだけど
妄想の時は実感さえもないんです
無知の場合は 実感さえもない場合はどうしますかね
どうにもならん 以上の 3つの思考を発見できます
欲の思考 怒りの思考 加害的な思考を発見できます
それを管理することで理性と智慧が現れて無知がなくなるんです
それ管理すると何か理性が出てくるんですよ
理性が現れたら無知がなくなっているんです
だから無知が自動的になくなるんです
それは考えてお釈迦様が説かれたんです
だから決してブッダの言葉は微塵も訂正してはならないんです
大変なことになります
恐ろしい 完璧なんです
もう怖いほど完璧なんです
次のダイコトミーオブソーツという
ちょっと日本語の単語がなくてそうしましたけどね
意味は言いますからね
対立的な概念に二分化するという意味
これ辞書から取ったんです
意味 対立的な概念に対立的な概念に二分化する
時々禅を哲学的に喋る人々はね
我々にちょっとけなされたりしますね
もう仏教はあれもあれもこれもね
区別 区別 分別ばっかしやと
我々は全部一緒くにとっているんだと
とかね ダイコトミーはバイフカーションと英語で
まだこれはちょっと間違えるんです
ダイコトミーというのは
これちょっと医学などなど使う単語なんです
思い出せなかったんです
正しい単語はバイフカーションなんです
今思い出したっても遅いんです
仏教は堂々と何でも 全く対立的に二分化するんです
これはマジュリニカーヤの 19番目の
経典でドゥエーダーヴィタッカ
思考を二つに分けなさいと
思考をカーンヴィタッカ
ヴェーパーダヴィタッカ
ヴィンサヴィタッカを一つのグループにするんです
この経典はお釈迦様が悟る前に
どのように菩薩でいた時は思考を管理したのかということを教えたんです
私は悟る前にこんなことをやりましたよと
お釈迦様は妄想で結構悩んだんですよ
特にお釈迦様みたいな性格的に知恵型なんですね
というか 仏典では思考型と言ってますけどね
どちらか分からない お釈迦様のことは
そうなってくると ものすごい思考で
妄想は難しいんです あらゆる思考が割り込んでくるんです
これ やめなくちゃいけなかったんです
でお釈迦様は自分がどうやってすごい思考のする
ものすごい方でしたからね
やめた方を教えているんですね
自分 で 前言った３つありますね
悪い思考３つ それは一つのカテゴリーに入れる
カーンヴィタッカ ヴェーパーダヴィタッカ
ヴィンサヴィタッカは一つの袋に入れる
ネッカンヴィタッカ アッヴェーパーダヴィタッカ
ヴィヒンサヴィタッカはもう一つの袋に入れて
しっかりと二分化する
欲の思考と欲から離れる思考
怒りの思考と怒りをなくす思考
害意的な思考と加害者にならない親切な思考というふうに
2つに2つに分ける そして欲思考など
属性を語るなどのなんですけどね
はい  2つに分けてもらった
あの科学者もよくやりますね
生物学でもね 植物も動物
生物もいろんなグループに分けてるでしょ
そうすると何か属性があるんですね
例えばクラシシアンという
生命がいますね で 言えばカニとかエビとかね
で ある何か似ているんですね
虫といってもね もういろいろ属性がありますね
それでこの悪いと と思った
このやめる思考 悪思考の袋にある属性は何なのかと教えてくれるんです １
アッタッヴェーバーダー
自分の破滅に不幸になる思考です
この袋2つに思考 思考妄想
袋2つに入れるんです
入れて一つの袋は これは自分の破滅に不幸になる思考だと
それからパラッバーダー
バーダー 他人の破滅に
点々だからね 自動 ご自分で読んでください
他人の破滅に不幸になる思考
ウベアッヴェーダー 両方の破滅に不幸になる思考と
だから この一つの袋の思考は
自分の破滅 他人の破滅
両方の破滅になりますよと
それからパンニャーニロディコ
智慧を滅するんで 智慧が現れとうもないんです
無知だけ現れるんです
ヴィガータパッキコ 悩み
苦悩の仲間 この妄想は悩みやら苦しみやら苦悩の仲間である
いわゆる細菌ですね ヴィーラスの袋ですね
だから自分の思考を袋 2つに入れて
ヴィーラスの袋は一つくるんで
全部ヴィーラスなるものをその袋に入れる
それからもう一つ アニッバーネサンワッテニク
安穏に涅槃に導かない思考であると
自分の他人のみんなの破壊になる思考
智慧が智慧を破壊する
安穏にならない思考は一つの袋
この 2つの属性を考えただけでも
この一つの属性を考えただけでも
悪思考がなくなるんです
お釈迦様そう言うんです
あ こんなことを考えたら自分がダメになるんだと思っただけで思考がなくなるんだと
こんなことを考えるとみんなに迷惑やと思った時点で思考がなくなる
こんなのはもうみんなの私にも他人の不幸になると思っただけで
こんなことは無知な思考やと
もう智慧が現れないんだと思ったら消えるんだと
だからこの属性を見ただけで悪思考が消えちゃ消えちゃうんだよと
それで悪思考をやめるんですね
やめるんじゃなくて やめてしまいますね
止めてしまいます 善思考の属性は異常の属性の反対です
省略します 善思考というのは自分のためになる
他人のためになる 両方のためになる
それから えーとなんでしたっけ
忘れた ん？智慧は最後
悩み苦しみの仲間である
智慧の反対でね まあ智慧が現れるというのはそちら反対ですね
善思考だったら智慧が現れる
悩みがなくなる 苦悩がなくなる
涅槃に導く 善思考を日夜続けても
何の問題も起こりませんよと
自分が善思考妄想でも構いませんよ
善思考妄想になったら
もう日夜やったっても
何の危険性もないんです
どんどん幸福になるだけ
えーと もう一つポイントがありますけど
先に郵便引きか後で書いていると思いますけど
じゃあ性格と思考に行きます
え 性格によって思考が変わるんでしょうか
例えば そのその人がいろいろ思考してるでしょ
それはその人の性格 ですかね
いつでも不機嫌で批判的で
もう怒りの思考ばっかりするのはその人の性格ですとか言えますか？とか
あるいは逆ですかね 思考によって性格が変わるんですかね
どちらとも そのその人は自分の性格によって思考パターンが決まってるんですかね
あるいは思考パターンによって性格が変わっていくんですかね
お釈迦様の言葉があります
ヤンヤデワビッカーレビッコバフラマヌヴィタッケーティアヌヴィチャーレーティアヌヴィチャーレーティタタタタナティーホーティチェータソー
大体私はパーリ語でいるの
この学者なんかには興味のない
発見もできないポイントだけ
あの で これちょっと日本訳難しいんだから
英訳で我慢してください
で ワットエバーパーソンシンクスフリークエンティ
ザットパーソンイズコンディションドバイザタイプオブトーツという
どうしますかね じゃあまあ適当な日本語訳
思考妄想で性格は変わるんです
だから美なんです 答えは
お釈迦様そうおっしゃっているんです
でもこれは適当な日本語訳ですよ
あの これはもう色になり立ちます
お釈迦様のパーリ語で言っているものは
もう何の色も成り立たないんです
微妙な言葉なんです で
私も皆様に分かりやすい英語にしたんであって
真面目に英訳すると もう辞書が必要になるんです
理解するために結構難しい心理学の単語を使わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
まあ一応単純にね 思考で性格が変わると思った方が話が終わり
ということは 善思考で善人になるんですかね
悪思考で悪人になる 善思考で善人になるでしょ
だって思考で性格変わりますから
その通りです 確かに善思考では人格者にはなるんです
しかし 釈尊はさらに超越した解脱の涅槃の境地を目指しているんです
お釈迦様はかっこいい人間になったら
あ よかったよかったです
それはダメです 結構高いところまで喋るんです
えーと 座ってみようかなと思います
だからこの仏教はただ善思考になっただけでは終わらないんです
したがって善思考も制御するんです
なぜならば 思考そのものが悪いんです
善悪と問題じゃないんです
だから瞑想する方々はいきなり一切思考を壊すプログラムに入りますけど
そこをいきなりできればありがたい
できない方々は幼稚園から頑張らなくちゃいけない
その場合は悪思考をやめて善思考を育てて
それから善思考を乗り越えるという順番になります
善思考は安全ですが 日夜続けると体を切れないで体は疲れるんですよ
思考するとかなり疲れる
クタクタ疲れますよ だからみんなストレスいっぱいたまってるでしょ？ものすごく疲れてるでしょ
あれ 肉体疲労じゃないんです
特に日本の社会を見たら
肉体労働っていうのはほとんどないんでしょうね
ビルなんか作る人々も全部機械でやってるんだから
もう釘を押す場合でも
ズシッとそれで終わり
全部もう機械でやってますよ
疲れるはずがないんです
でっかいコンクリートを上げて
なんとかなんとかビルね
もう 40階まで作りますからね
2 キロぐらいの品物も運ばないんです
手で疲れないんです だから我々の疲労は何ですかね
この疲労は 思考妄想しているだからなんです
ひどいもんでしょ で まあ田んぼとかやる場合は労働なんですけど
それも日本ではないんですね
全部機械で 田植えも機械で
稲刈りも機械で 何もやってないんですね
だから 80歳のおじいさんも立派に田んぼを作っているんです
で 機械に乗っちゃえばお話終わりですから
これ 例えば稲刈りする場合はね
あの機械を持っていったら
もうゆっくりお茶飲んで
コーヒーも飲んで パンも食べて
おにぎりも食べながらちょこちょこっと持っていくだけ
それで稲を刈りて束になって畳んでもいるんですね
機械が全部 やること何もないんです
疲れるわけじゃないんです
それでも田舎のね 農業をやっている方々は疲れます
あれやこれやとかね まあいいつつもやってますよ
本当は疲れてないんです
欲を言えば 都会に住んでいる人々ほど病気じゃないんだからね
やってはいるんですけど
でお釈迦様は教えてますよ
この体の疲労っていうのは
思考妄想で起こるんです
すっごく疲れるんです
次 カエキランてチッタンウーハンね
体が疲れると心が乱れるんです
でしょ もう体の調子が悪くなるともう落ち着いていられる場合じゃないんです
ウーハテーチッテーアーラーチッタンサマーディー
心が乱れると 心は統一
落ち着き 定サマーディーがから離れるんです
心はダメになっちゃいます
サマーディがなくなるんです
統一性がなくなるんです
統一っていうのは 心はものすごい力強くすることなんです
それはできないんです
体が疲れると 体が思考で疲れるんです
たとえ善思考であっても
それで善思考も止めて集中力を育てるんです
それで最後の超越したいステップ
善思考も止めることにするんです
で 崖の例えがあります
これも同じ経典にあります
ちょっと例えがちょっとあんまり正しくは書いてないんですけど
たくさん動物が住んでいる森に巨大な崖があります
すごい怖い崖があります
悪人が安全な道をすべて閉ざして
危険な道を開いて開けておく
いわゆる崖に行く道だけ開けて
他の道を全部閉ざすんですね
もう悪人って狩人にしましょう
そうすると鹿たちは餌を食べながら
行けないところは行けませんだからね
行けるところに行って崖から落ちるんです
崖から落ちると狩人がはい
もらったもんやって言って持っていくんです
狩る狩る必要ないんです
崖の下で待っていればいいんです
家族で一緒に みんなで
そこで一匹落ちたらもう持っていく
食べる また一匹落ちたら待って持っていくという
あの これはお釈迦様ではなくて
善人はと言った方がいいんですけど
善人は危険な道を完全に閉ざして
安全な道を開いておく
皆幸福になる それで殺生したくない
動物のことを哀れむ人が来て
崖の道を閉ざしておくんです
行けないようにしておくんです
安全な道は全部開けておくんです
それで鹿たちがもう食べて食べて食べて
どこを遊んで遊んで遊んで
もう子供を作って 年取って自然に死ぬ
幸福になる この例えってお釈迦様が私があなた方のことはものすごく心配しているんだと
それでお釈迦様は自分の職業は何でしたっけ？お釈迦様の職業は
知らないでしょう お釈迦様の職業は師匠なんです
先生なんです で 自分がこのサッター師匠ですからね
師匠として やるべきことは全部やっているんだと
そういう言葉を入れてこう言うんです
このお釈迦様がこの危険な悪思考に壁をかけて
危険でない良い思考をするようにして
それもやがて疲れるんだから
その道も閉ざしている
それで悟りに達するしかないんですと
これは例えですよと この妄想思考について
だから我々妄想が楽しくてやってる人々は
この崖を目掛けて一方的に走っているんです
落ちるんです 妄想は完全にすべて悪思考なんです
だから自然に我々は悪思考する
だから頑張って善思考しなくちゃいけないんです
ちょっと頑張らないと
頑張って善思考すると幸福になりますけど
調子に乗ってやろうかなと思っちゃうと
やっぱりそちらでもやっぱり壁があるんですね
やっぱり疲れるんですね
そうすると思考をすべて止めるというところになってしまって
それで悟りに達しますよと
お釈迦様はその経典を終わって
私はあなた方のことを心配して
師匠として 先生としてやるべきことは全部やりましたと
この経典 それで終了するんです
これは思考の制御に関する例ですね
経典がそれで終わり 話もそろそろ終わります